so let's talk about this new show yes it
seems to be hilarious we had a great
time making out our cast is hilarious
our writers are amazing I'm super
excited you're asking me the obvious
question right like this is a dream
project for me and for Matt Murray my
co-creator we're so excited that we got
to create the show and hopefully make
people laugh so obviously the issue of
immigration it's a very serious issue
you guys are making it funny what was
that like so the initial idea for the
show is something my manager and I had
tossed around about five years ago he
said kal you first you should start
pitching stuff and I was like that's the
thing I can do I didn't know there was a
thing I gave you guys yeah what would
you want a pitch dream project it's a
dream project I love making people laugh
and I love America so something that
incorporates both I grew up outside of
New York City so a lot of the show's I
grew up watching like Seinfeld or
friends or Fresh Prince obviously didn't
take place in New York but a lot of the
fish-out-of-water stories or the stories
about New York but you know friends and
Seinfeld were at different New York than
mine New York like what if we make it
the 2019 New York so we started
developing it it just so happens
obviously now the topic of immigration
is sort of in the news but look America
was founded by immigrants it's been our
history so so we just wanted to make a
comedy about it yeah obviously you're no
stranger to the White House I feel like
you know about you know immigration and
politics and all of these things and
you're friends with the Obamas really
cool what are the chances we can get the
Obamas on this show well so we're not
trying to make a political show and but
the reason is you look at those shows
that we all grew up watching for any
sitcom or comedy to succeed the
characters have to be grounded it's our
first season I loved the office and 30
rock because of how absurd the scenarios
were so first season at least we're
focusing on creating that absurd world
and and hopefully we'll have some
amazing cameos throughout we had Bill
Nye in the Phi
which was awesome and there's also this
weird litmus that I always tell people
where I remember when we made Harold and
Kumar Go to Guantanamo Bay right a lot
of people were wondering is this a
political comedy we're like no we're
going to great lengths to make sure that
people either know it's a satire that
everybody can enjoy that movie right
similar to this like obviously it's
topical but if we do this right we want
everybody from all walks of life to love
the comedy aspect of it and I remember
when we met a bunch of Republicans who
had gone to seeing it see Harold and
Kumar escape from Guantanamo Bay in DC
they stopped us on the street like hey
we love that movie we work for the Bush
White House what'd you do yeah that was
really funny when Harold and Kumar
smoked weed with President Bush it's
like it was like an was that supposed to
be a slam was like no it was supposed to
be funny I'm glad you guys liked it so
that was sort of been our litmus of we
want to create grounded characters that
everybody can just laugh with and I hope
we get to do that here yeah do you think
a show like this can bring about change
maybe yeah I mean look any time you
share the experiences of characters with
audiences I think it can I think comedy
in and of itself has has always been
something that's unifying and you know
no matter what people's politics are
anywhere in the world really if you look
at things that are happening in Europe
and in Asia South America obviously here
in North America things are contentious
and polarizing and what I love about
making people laugh is for that half
hour every week you can tune out the
rest of the world sit down with your
friends and family and just enjoy a show
is there any other guest appearances
that you can even just hint at we are
trying to staff up now so we're about to
shoot episode 2 bill nye was our big
guest star in episode 1 no shortage of
opportunities for our guests in episode
2 and the rest of the season
I don't know can you hook up with
Trudeau if you I mean if you can get
Brock or a Drake
let's go non-political let's go Drake I
just spent three years in Toronto and I
miss it so much so I'm like you know
about Toronto we shot designated
survivor in Toronto all three seasons
what do you know like where are you
eating where are you going
I like local I like so I lived I lived
between Queen and King West for most of
the time that I was there and we shot
and downs of you for the first two
seasons then Etobicoke so we were kind
of all over yeah but I'm like I'm more
of like the roti shop that's by the way
like the ones that are only open three
days a week why are you only open three
days a week you may work weird hours I
need you to be open more often than that
yeah let's talk to them that's not
Gandhi roti on Queen I'm looking at you
I know and there's some bomb food in
China you know I do miss it go get your
passport